I remember when I first found out I was
going to speak at a TED conference I ran
across the hall to one of my classrooms
then for my students guess what guys
I've been asked to give a TED talk the
reaction wasn't when I quite expected
the whole room went silent a TED talk
you mean like the one you made us watch
on grit or the one with a scientist that
did this really awesome thing with
robots who have my bath yes just like
that
the coach those people are really
important and smart I know that but
coach why are you speaking you hate
public speaking I do I admitted but it's
important that I speak about us that I
speak about your journeys about my
journey people need to know the students
at the ole refugee school that I founded
decided to end with some words of
encouragement cool it better be good
coach there are 60 5.3 million people
who have been forcibly displaced from
their homes because of war or
persecution the largest number 11
million are from Syria 33 thousand nine
hundred and fifty two people flee their
homes daily the vast majority remain in
refugee camps those conditions cannot be
defined as humane under anyone's
definition we are participating in the
degradation of humans neverhood we have
numbers this high this is the highest
number of refugees since World War two
now let me tell you why this issue is so
important to me I'm an Arab I'm an
immigrant I'm a Muslim I've also spent
the last 12 years of my life working
with refugees oh and I'm also gay it
makes me really popular these days
but I am the daughter of a refugee my
grandmother fled Syria in 1964 during
the first f ed regime she was three
months pregnant when she packed up a
suitcase piled in her five children and
drove to neighboring Jordan not knowing
what the future held for her and her
family my grandfather decided to stay
not believing it was that bad he
followed her a month later after his
brothers were tortured and this factory
was taken over by the government they
rebuilt their lives starting from
scratch and eventually became
independently wealthy Jordanian citizens
I was born in Jordan eleven years later
it was really important to my
grandmother for us to know our history
in our journey I was eight years old
when she took me to visit my first
refugee camp I didn't understand why and
it know why it was so important to her
for us to go I remember walking into the
camp holding her hand
and her saying go play with the kids
while she visited with the women in the
camp I didn't want to these kids weren't
like me they were poor they lived in a
camp I refused she knelt down beside me
and firmly said go and don't come back
until you've played they'll ever think
people are beneath you or that you have
nothing to learn from others I
reluctantly went I never wanted to
disappoint my grandmother I returned a
few hours later having spent some time
playing soccer with the kids in the camp
we walked out of the camp and I was
excitedly telling her what a great time
I had and how fantastic the kids were
hey Dom I said in Arabic pour them hadam
on us she said using the words different
meaning that we were sinning don't feel
sorry for them believe in them it wasn't
until I left my country of origin for
the United States that I realized the
impact of her words after my college
graduation I applied for and was granted
political asylum based on being a member
of a social group some people may not
realize this that you can still get the
death penalty in some countries for
being gay I had to give up my Jordanian
citizenship that was the hardest
decision I've ever had to make but I had
no other choice the point is when you
find yourself choosing between home and
survival the question where are you from
becomes very loaded a Syrian woman who I
recently met at a refugee camp in Greece
articulated best when she called the
exact moment she realized she had to
flee Aleppo I looked out the window and
there was nothing it was all rubble
there were no stores no streets no
schools everything was gone I've been in
my apartment for months listening to
bombs drop and watching people die but I
always thought it would get better but
no one could force me to leave no one
could take my home away from me and I
don't know why it was that morning but
when I looked outside I realized if I
didn't leave my three young children
would die and so we left we left because
we had to not because we wanted to there
was no choice she said it's kind of hard
to believe that you belong when you
don't have a home when your country of
origin rejects you because of fear or
persecution or the city that you grew up
in is completely destroyed I didn't feel
like I had a home I was no longer a
Jordanian citizen but I wasn't American
either I felt a kind of loneliness is
still hard to put into words
today after college I desperately needed
to find a place to call home I bounced
around from state to state and
eventually ended up in North Carolina
kind-hearted people felt sorry for me
offered to pay rent or buy me a meal or
suit for my new interview it just made
me feel more isolated and incapable it
wasn't until I met Miss Sarah a Southern
Baptist who took me in at my lowest and
gave me a job that I started to believe
in myself
Miss Sarah owned a diner in the
mountains of North Carolina I assumed
because my privileged upbringing in my
seven sister education that she would
ask me to manage the restaurant I was
wrong
I started off washing dishes cleaning
toilets and working the grill I was
humbled
the value of hard work but most
importantly I felt valued and embraced I
fell abraded Christmas with her family
and she attempted to observe Ramadan
with me I remember being very nervous
about coming out to her after all she
was a Southern Baptist I sat on the
couch next to her and I said Miss Sarah
you know that I'm gay her response is
one that I will never forget that's fine
honey just don't be a I event I
eventually moved to Atlanta still trying
to find my home my journey took a
strange turn three years later after I
met a group of refugee kids playing
soccer outside I made a wrong turn into
this apartment complex and I saw these
kids outside playing soccer
they were playing barefoot with a
raggedy soccer ball and rock set up his
goals
I watched them for about an hour and
after that I was smiling
the boys reminded me of home they
reminded me of the way I grew up playing
soccer in the streets of Jordan with my
brothers and cousins I eventually joined
their game they're a little skeptical
about letting me join it because
according to them girls don't know how
to play but obviously I did I assume
they have ever played on a team they
said they hadn't but that they would
love to I gradually won them over and we
formed our first team this group of kids
would give me a crash course in refugees
poverty and humanity three brothers from
Afghanistan
Rulon Narula and xàbia Love played a
major role in that I showed up late to
practice one day to find the field
completely deserted I was really worried
my team loves to practice it wasn't like
them to miss practice I got out of my
car and two kids ran out from behind a
dumpster waving their hands frantically
coach shrew got beat up he got jumped
there was blood everywhere what do you
mean what do you mean he got beat up
these bad kids came and they beat him up
coach everybody left they were all
scared we hopped into my car and drove
over to Roos apartment I knocked on the
door and Noor opened it where's ro I
need to talk to him see if he's okay
he's in his room coach is refusing to
come out
and knocked on the door Roo come on out
I need to talk to you and you'd see if
you're okay if we need to go to the
hospital he came out and a big gash on
his head a split lip and he was visibly
shaken I was looking at him and I asked
the boys to call for their mom because I
needed to go to the hospital with him
they called for their mom she came out I
had my back turned to her and she
started screaming in Farsi the boys fell
to the ground laughing I was very
confused because there's nothing funny
about this
they explained to me that she said you
told me your coach was a Muslim and a
woman from behind
I didn't appear to be either to her I am
Muslim I said turning to her a Shadrin
Bella and Lala reciting a Muslim
declaration of faith confused and
perhaps maybe a little bit reassured she
realized that yes I this American acting
shorts wearing non veiled woman was
indeed a Muslim their family had fled
the Taliban hundreds of people in their
village were murdered their father was
taken in by the Taliban only to return a
few months later a shell of the man he
once was the family escaped to Pakistan
and the two older boys aged 8 and 10 at
the time wove rugs for 10 hours a day to
provide for their family they were so
excited when they found out that they
had been approved to resettle in the
United States making them the lucky 0.1%
who get to do that they had hit the
jackpot
their story is not unique every refugee
family I have worked with is at some
version of this I work with kids who've
seen their mothers raped their father's
finger sliced off one kid saw a bullet
put in his grandmother's head because
she refused to let the rebels take him
to be a child soldier their journeys are
haunting but what I get to see every day
is hope resilience determination a love
of life and appreciation for being able
to rebuild their lives
I was at the boys apartment one night
when the mom came home after cleaning 18
hotel rooms in one day she sat down and
Noor rubbed her feet saying that he was
going to take care of her once he
graduated she smiled from exhaustion god
is good life is good we are lucky to be
here
in the last two years we have seen an
escalating anti-refugee sentiments its
global the numbers continue to grow
because we do nothing to prevent it and
nothing to stop it
the issue shouldn't be stopping refugees
from coming into our countries the issue
should be not forcing them to leave
their own
[Applause]
sorry
how much more sorry how much more
suffering
how much more suffering must we take how
much more people need to be forced out
of their homes before we say enough 100
million not only do we shame blame and
reject them for atrocities but they had
absolutely nothing to do with wery
traumatized them when we were supposed
to be welcoming them into our countries
we stripped them of their dignity and
treat them like criminals I had a
student in my office a couple of weeks
ago she's originally from Iraq she broke
down crying why do they hate us who
hates you everyone everyone hates us
because we are refugees because we are
Muslim in the past I was able to
reassure my students that the majority
of the world does not hate refugees but
this time I couldn't I couldn't explain
to her why someone tried to rip off her
mother's hijab when they were grocery
shopping or why a player on an opposing
team
called her terrorists and told her to go
back where she came from I couldn't
reassure her that her father's ultimate
like life sacrifice by serving in the
United States military as an interpreter
would make her more valued as an
American citizen we take in so few
refugees worldwide we resettle less than
0.1% that point 1% benefits us more than
them it dumbfound me how the word
refugee is considered something to be
dirty something to be ashamed of they
have nothing to be ashamed of we have
seen advances in every aspect of our
lives
except our humanity there are 60 5.3
million people who have been forced out
of their homes because of war the
largest number in history we are the
ones who should be ashamed thank you
[Applause]